ah hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a few horror games
now we're starting off with one called
Courage's curse which if you remember
Courage the Cowardly Dog you might
remember that there was a being that
didn't like Eustace having that slab and
Eustace didn't want to return sad slab
but I don't remember me real being all
demonic and evil over there in the
corner so we're gonna get through a few
war games today and we're starting off
with this one because I couldn't resist
I love Courage the Cowardly Dog I've
never I think maybe once I've played a
game about Courage the Cowardly Dog but
does about it once used to subdue in the
slab he decided to bury it in his
basement to prevent anyone from stealing
it
but King Ramses was not happy about this
he's now out for blood and will do
whatever it takes to get back his slab
even if it means possessing Muriel to
find the slab and kill anyone who gets
um Uriel's or his way is that what
happened and I remember poor Muriel
Muriel now please I'm sister I'm just an
innocent little dog I think yes I am
retrieved King Ramsay oh wait wait a
minute
wait a minute I'm unsure about that
phase they're you Eustace you see is
that you stupid dog okay I'm assuming
that's you it was just weird waking up
next to useless but I guess it's okay
that a you know a dog can sleep on the
bed it was just me waking up next to
useless that was a bit shocking oh this
looks good
hi hello oh gosh oh oh I'm sorry I'm
getting do it shut up I'm working on it
oh my gosh I think the only time that
I've ever played anything Courage the
Cowardly Dog related was when I plays
like a gmod map do you have the call for
the padlock that's the basement door no
I don't that's a problem hey hey hey
stop that
I can make weird noises do blue little
okay all right thank you
Oh something printed out something I got
the code Oh by arielle problem whoa whoa
all right sorry I'm sorry this is so
stupid
oh where we go off [ __ ] I got the code I
like it I mean how do I get downstairs I
just got it it's locked I need to find a
key to remove it
okay so I got the code but I need a key
what a shitty dicks alrighty then Muriel
food water nothing open five sorry five
Muriel you
ah [ __ ] sorry oh that's not right either
okay well we've got a lot of problems
and I don't know what to do about it
I think I need to maybe give you some
coupons maybe I can use the car to bust
down the door
I guess that's logical conclusion okay
gotta find the car keys first
okay all right here we go where the
Frick of the car keys [ __ ] that's not
good all right okay all right hello are
you doing please stop I'm already
suffering your curse stop the game is a
goddamn I found nothing you're goddamn
right I found nothing I am a useless
piece of garbage
I found car keys didn't expect to find
that on the first go okay let me get the
code printing and then I can come back
for it maybe okay do you have the code
all right so I got that working on that
I just need to go downstairs slam the
car
I'm sorry excuse you Mariel
[Music]
what's over here
nothing Allah
well I already got the keys why do I
need to look anymore Oh oh yeah why am I
still looking I don't need to look I got
lucky
okay can I jump okay got a cold all
right got a cold where's Muriel Muriel
if you Club me in the back of the head
with your rolling pin again I'm gonna be
very upset okay all right a prick to lay
a brick delay I could [ __ ] a brick
that'd probably help right probably not
okay well I don't know what you want
from me I know you want that slap from
me but I'm just looking for oh hi I'm
sorry pardon moi okay is there anything
in this goddamn cornfield no wait maybe
there is maybe there's a brick in the
cornfield oh it's all adding up it's all
adding up I'm really getting it up in my
brain Oh someone's an eager beaver I
couldn't really go search the cabinets
for a brick oh that's not good
all right
oh nothing
okay I don't think I'm gonna find a
break in here guys hey what's wrong
I totally found a brick he didn't notice
me but idiot
well yeah and she dumb as a brick and I
just happened to also okay okay
wash Bowie Bowie I got it okay well
that's that's problematic okay all right
get up here
no you can't even go up there there it
is how's a good boy all right
wait for him to go by otherwise I'm go
by yeah okay so I just gotta go dig up
this [ __ ] and then I got the code
and then I got the key I'm not risking
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you owe me RL what are
you doing outside come on
oh well I'm double boned our night Teddy
sprinkles no now what I have everything
[Music]
I don't wanna suffer your ass I don't
wanna cover your ears okay no I just go
out here
[Music]
oh my god
let's carry the pieces out of me
oh I had everything I know I probably
could have just gone for the cornfield
but I didn't know if it was gonna be
like sit me there for a second Muriel
j'son's close it close it close it there
we go that's how you do it that's how
you do it okay you stay up here for a
bit I gotta go you know look around
I've got nothing I don't have a key or a
brick I found nothing good I was hoping
for nothing and I found nothing great
now I don't have any expectations about
myself Oh brick okay there's Muriel
Muriel is coming back this way I don't
know where slabby man is but I'm open
Muriel just go upstairs go upstairs
Muriel no that's sour gnome York Muriel
please Muriel oh my god Muriel you are
goddamn terrifying well I don't like you
where's slappy man okay that's problem
okay gonna risk this it's gotta be in
here right it's gotta be in here it's
not in here I'm boned it was if I'm
boned then I'm dead
oh nothing have nothing but that's
impossible it can't be nothing it's
gotta be something oh that's okay well
why is that interactable oh here yes
why was that
I don't know what happened I found
nothing
oh hi well oh wait I've a glee remember
you okay last place I guess mm-hmm
always in the lack o burial don't come
in here
Mariel no Barrow don't go okay I think
we're okay I can shove my head in the
toilet if I'm if I'm not okay okay okay
Oh
Muriel Howdy Doody that's not good okay
there's slab man okay that's perfect
no close the door and let's get to ramen
my favorite part of the day ramen and
then I'm just gonna take the shovel and
I'm gonna go for the cornfield cuz if if
it stops me then I mean I guess there's
just nothing to do anyway oh [ __ ] here
he comes
no [ __ ]
yeah that's right you better break off
your chase man those clouds are a
whipping those are some Oh whoopee
whoopee clouds
all right gone he gone I got my shovel
now I'm gonna go dig in the cornfield
corn key corn cob key here we go give me
corn give oh oh I got actually fine it
oh this [ __ ] I got see this why
didn't just go for it
oh well I am oh it was there where are
you okay please tell me that oh oh what
am I stopped oh okay where are you I
can't see [ __ ] oh that's not good
I just got it okay I'm gonna lose him
around the corner of the barn it was
right there [ __ ] come on man god
dammit god dammit I should just gone for
it I should just gone for it why didn't
I go for it
I'm a [ __ ] idiot Oh Oh found the car
keys
yes what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] Muriel
don't do that to me
Miriam girl girl come on I don't trust
like that Muriel I don't trust like that
I know you're coming
why don't you come along then
I knew I knew I [ __ ] knew no on that
side of the door why is this so hard
oh [ __ ] there she is there she okay I
see the tip okay alright then that's all
okay All Right see ya okay
easy is that huh easy as that you think
but maybe not please I'm begging you
Murray Murray Murray more Miller more oh
god I hope the brick isn't up there
god damn it oh I'm Fox found a bag okay
we're good we're good we're good let's
go slam this [ __ ]
let's go slam this [ __ ] slam that like
button slam those comments plan that
Bell what have I become
well that's not good okay that's a
problem yes okay here we go here we go
zips up loop no no no no no no don't see
me no no no don't see me no don't do it
don't they know I'm forging don't do it
okay so now I just have to get back in
when Muriel ain't there make sense ooh
make a sense uh yeah I make a sense up
okay
anybody see Muriel get the slab where's
the slob get the slab get the swab
that's a good slab now I gotta return
you
can I please just go out this way oh no
I can't okay
please Muriel don't be right there
Muriel if you're oh there's your [ __ ]
slab King Ram [ __ ] the end
oh the harrowing adventure harrowing on
so many levels
that's good it looks so [ __ ] but luckily
it worked for him some weird respect and
also the nostalgia trip was very good
there and also [ __ ] like these two
like these two and Eustace I thought you
was Eustace that got all buckled ducked
over all right whatever
all right so that was fun but moving on
to the next one okay so this one this
one's gonna be a big shift in mood this
one's called safety blanket
imagine you're good and you were
snuggled up under your blanket but you
realize your blankets just not long
enough to cover your feet and you know
that if you go to sleep and your feet
are uncovered that's an opportunity for
the monster under your bed
to grab you by your ankle and drag you
down be a better than even better day
right make sense everyone knows this is
true it's bedtime the monsters are out
to get you and your blanket it's just
too small to cover your body exactly
what I just said
cover your exposed limbs to fend off the
approaching tentacles the tentacles will
only go for your feet hands and head
obviously they don't give a [ __ ] about
the body
if the tentacles reach you it's game
over survive until 7000 Mike what it oh
my god what us what why are you sleeping
whoa what are you what kind of shadow
puppet I mean the scariest thing I've
never seen
I'm sorry it's not that money hurts
this is just not at all what I expected
I mean the image that I saw it was like
this isn't enticing in a way I guess
but this cover the cover your shame
cover your shame hey hey I wish you was
naked under here not that I'm not that I
wish he was naked under here don't give
me don't get me wrong one is bad I don't
see off the tutsis often pay off the
good seas off the chrome dome hang-hang
whoa whoa hey whoa
get your oh my god don't cry baby boy
Don't Cry please oh gosh [ __ ] well the
night creeps really try that again
yeah now that I know the proper
stratagem which might just be to let him
like it's flailing around so much oh I
would okay let's see cover that cover
that
no no no no
you don't want none of this you know
what that nice yeah yeah the trick is
multi-surface [ __ ] not let it get
off swamp gup-e back off you back off
you don't want none of this no no no no
no cover it covered
oh yeah you know ain't no nightmares
here ain't no nightmares here ain't no
nightmares no no no no no I don't think
so no no I don't I don't I said I don't
think so you don't want those tits ease
those since these are not for you no no
no no no not for you not for you not for
you maybe it's just it is a good
strategy to just keep them flailing nope
that's definitely not a good strategy no
no no no these tutsies are off limit the
Handy wendy is not for you Randy okay
that head muncher he's gonna be coming
pretty soon of a funny feeling oh yeah
there is no no no no just go I just got
to cover the face the top of the head
and oh no worried about that now worried
about that all right who are you no no
no no no
you guys go away you guys go away no no
no no no no come on now you're being
ridiculous your favorite goddamn dick
ulis with you're being ridiculous
let's not wall away okay all right there
all right all right okay no I know I
know
oh that's problem no it's let's not do
that let's let [ __ ] Patrol oh I had the
toy sorry
it's terrifying is Tara I'm gonna do one
more time I I don't think I'm gonna be
able to get this out am take some
goddamn effort that's where they would
stop being a goddamn weirdo every
[ __ ] time I think it pays to make him
go away
like all the way away I think there's
there's some kind of better payoff for
that yeah the trick is to try to go for
three you're never gonna cover all of it
so when you can I guess go for three
just like basketball I think oh no no no
no no that that that head covering is
here way early whoa what the
good sailor well this just isn't fair
that's is not fair that's obviously uh
no not the kiss II wish II don't give it
kiss oh well all right that didn't work
out at all
okay all right that's enough of that one
ha ha I am now I'm gonna be able to beat
that one okay but if you wanna try that
I highly recommended it is a challenge
all right welcome to planet of
bloodthirsty sins if you remember power
drill massacre this made by the same
people oh boy
something's about to happen yeah I don't
know what then again I don't know what
to expect in the game that's called
planet of bloodthirsty Santa or why
anyone would want to go to Planet a
bloodthirsty Santa it's like Futurama
when Santo is a horrible murderous robot
but even worse somehow whoa
five active crew miss should collect the
mineral or in unclaimed sectors of
quadrant two scans from surface of fnc
133 to for have returned with the high
yield concentration of iron lithium and
two presumably undiscovered minerals oh
we will be leaving comfortably for the
rest of our lives
I've still got a bad feeling about this
planet Oh nonsense it's completely
uninhabited planet we'd fry David the
scan didn't pick up any life-forms still
it wouldn't hurt to bring some
protection god damn it don't be silly
bathe which is gonna do some quick
reconnaissance
yes would like the for minerals each and
return to the ship
David you head west and all go north but
Beth I'm gonna tell you this just once
but I wanna [ __ ] hear from you to
click four of those minerals all so help
me God Beth I'm gonna bust you down from
sink and officer so fast and I'm gonna
know what she knew
capiche come on guys it's freezing out
here let's get on with it okay
what a great wholesome team oh boy oh
I'm playing now yep okay yeah this is
very babysitter bloodbath and very much
power drill massacre which way was I
supposed to go I wasn't listening to you
being an [ __ ] so I don't really wool
also why were they so much taller than
me that didn't make a lot of sense I can
jump hey that's a that's a market
improvement from what I was doing before
whoo yeah whoo okay all right then where
am I going oh this way oh okay I found
it I found the way everybody follow me
to death or richness or aura busting
down from second officer I can
definitely smell the bloodthirsty Santa
and I don't know why Santa is
bloodthirsty or why he lives on this
planet all by himself but oh well oh
that's weird a tree mmm
Oh another tree that's Oh the forest
okay that's a little odd why are there
these things and what's that glowing up
on the hill over there
that's not good yeah Oh more true Oh Oh
candy cane that's bizarre I don't think
that's right whoa reminds me of a long
time ago and I played this Slenderman
Christmas special that was a goddamn
delight a house wait totally uninhabited
planet but there's a goddamn house here
oh no can't do that what is the e button
do Oh checks over that shoulder I guess
what's the point of that oh ah that's
normal
okay just gotta follow the candy cane
we're gonna jump for it I think
probably not but here
Oh jump oh [ __ ] missed my jump well
okay.i sorry I'll get back - I'm sorry -
pardon me pardon me sir okay made it
alright that was easy enough don't know
what that's all about
oh okay my favorite jams thank you for
playing me some Coldplay whoa [ __ ]
almost mess that up
hello ding dong oh did not expect that
to open not gonna lie also hello
Christmas tree o Christmas tree who look
I shiny thingy I don't know how to pick
you up
Oh found an out read it dil has been
gone for three days he thinks he can
just work us at that tired and we won't
notice that we notices though I'm not
gonna let him get away with this he
thinks that thousand-yard stare and cold
laugh is intimidating I'm going to his
castle tonight sneak in if I have to
this elf isn't gonna let him roll over
us that dill dill dill pickle from the
Rugrats
who are we talking about here we're
talking about Santa saint dill Saint
Nicholas now we're dying oh look a sack
that's fun oh no it's a ball sorry I
always get my sax confused with my balls
it's I'm going up to Santa's castle over
there which is a new thing but a welcome
thing to be sure
oh is that us oh that's a snowman in it
alright oh that's multiple snowman ah
sorry where am I going
llama gone oh that's not oh that's a
sweeping oh that's not good okay I gotta
make this jump apparently oh I guess we
go made it oh I guess I could have gone
behind that
okay so I'm guessing I shouldn't be seen
by that thing
oh that's not good oh that's very scary
okay all right well that's that's not
good I'm wondering the same thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay I'm guessing I don't wanna be
detected by wool boy boy boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
hmm okay go go go bud huh okay there's
another sort of building up here I don't
know what it is but let me see if I can
get inside oh good it's already pre
broken down I was hoping for this like
like die or something this is a fever
dreamers is for realsies oh look a note
read it
Santa's constantly appearing in the
village in the dead of night he stays
somewhat quiet just wandering around the
alleys I've seen him looking around
peeking through windows following else
home he's freaking us all the hell out I
mean Santa is the nicest guy he's never
done any boozing not that we've heard he
may be acting strange but I know he'd
never hurt us if you say so
whatever you say oh okay you're fine
that's fine that's nothing it's just a
cheapo jump-scare nothing I need to
worry about at all okay what is this
okay never mind okay hang on gonna get
up here Angela
this is really squeaks Cuong Carly okay
what's this found a sapphire pick it up
I got a mineral boy my friends are gonna
[Music]
who are you talking to yourself with let
me squeaks Wang Kang on Scootaloo
doodly-doo just got a crab walk over
here okay stop that what is that oh all
right whatever I got what I needed I
think let me see if there's anything
else here Oh where's that light oh
there's that light okay well um buff
I'll go this way then you don't get me
don't get me get me all right next house
all right I love this game oh never mind
can't go in that one can't go in that
one it's gonna not go in the I'm I
should know about this one up here is he
special can this be gone in what can it
go oh that blood okay all right this
ain't a good thing is the opposite of a
good thing hey look it's another mineral
found in turquoise
right yep almost there almost there baby
almost there all right oh well that's a
sound I don't know why that happened
but I'm gonna ignore it and carry on
with my life but up OK sneaks nonk found
a note all debts been missing ever since
she went to Santa's castle I don't know
what we're supposed to assume Kringle
had has has had this distance to
everything he's said lately like he's
not really talking to us of that makes
sense I'm worried that there's no real
end of this but a debt wanted to go talk
to him figure something out I have no
idea what I can do
well sounds like Kris Kringle went a
little crazy oh why why would you do
that to me why would you do that why
don't do that
I'll do that lights over there I don't
think there's anything else over here so
I'm assuming it's time to try to make my
way to the castle I guess I couldn't go
in this building there's another one
over there I don't know I don't know I'm
just trying to stay away from the light
whew this looks good enough to me whoa
whoa wait whoa easy oh boy oh boy
yi yi yi okay I'm alive okay I'm fine
can I go in this building please tell me
okay well if I could just stop power
jumping okay if I could get it off oh
okay I'll take the ramp bye David
something is trying to kill us we [ __ ]
you what the [ __ ] you why were you
talking about
Nicole Ferran is adding something
everything he does is so shifty he knows
something about this this shift in Santa
a few of us are planning a bit dialogue
a bit of dialogue with him when he
leaves the workshop tonight a few of us
are going to get some answers and that
little smiley bastard is going to give
us the answers so long as we avoid
Santa's searchlights we should be fine
we can't forget that dill still hasn't
come back since he was brought to Santa
Farren probably knows something about
that too I'm tired of waiting for
answers from Santa yeah me too baby me
too I want answers I guess where's this
sir sir
oh that's not good yeah
yeah well that's a problem that's
definitively a problem oh boy that
searchlight to stay in there okay okay
okay oh no it's just a red light oh just
the town is bathed in blood oh these
poor elves okay I can't go in there
I'm going to Santa I'm coming for you
baby I'm coming for you thought you
could get away with all your murder
boys it's camping right this is
backtracking how do we get to your
goddamn whoa how do we get oh that sweet
oh the toy factory Oh God how could I be
so stupid guards I go to the toy bag oh
this looks important
that jolly rad red [ __ ] is crazy if he
thinks we're gonna take this we've done
nothing to loyal productive these walls
right hours every year bigger numbers
shorter dates I'm trying to lose it this
right we'll be dead oh okay can i okay
no all right well a problem problem
problem problem problem let me let me in
[ __ ] let me in oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh oh okay I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I
think I'm fine oh don't go that way okay
well that didn't help anybody at all how
do we get into the toy factory
I don't know huh here we go whoa okay I
found one that was finally open well
it's a good thing we split up to cover
more ground and sure I'm happy that I'm
taking this on alone ooh that's an
ominous red globe hey no great let's do
it let's do this there we go let's do
this
who the hell this fair and thing he is
the cheery little [ __ ] he just keeps
giving those [ __ ] ridiculous orders
same smile on his stupid face is he
pretending that nothing is different
hell he's the only one that even looks
at us anymore I think I've seen Santa
once this last month and that was in the
dead of night he was just standing in
the square the villages just looking
around I don't know what he's planning
it finally going senile
have that's all it is okay hate that
hate that hate that on Ruby
alright okay alright hurry okay Thank
You Susan whoever that is the hell Susan
so there's gotta be one more house that
I haven't found yet maybe I don't know
whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh what is happening I
don't know what happening don't like
that huh okay I'm out of who Jesus John
I'm out of there
okay that's no good that's no good for
anybody especially not me not me in my
sensitive supple body oh that's not good
I don't know maybe I missed the very
first house that came up maybe I could
have gone in there and I didn't I don't
know I don't know man I'm really trying
here really trying was this there's this
way - oh that's right this doesn't God
can you oh my god can you stop please oh
why why oh come on oh [ __ ] me okay okay
here's the first house and I was [ __ ]
locked all the time it was
oh wow oh why oh hi hello hi Santa what
are you doing here what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay hi oh I don't think I want to give
you any of my blood where did you come
from oh my god he's still there okay
he's still there
well I think actually I'm kind of going
into a got into a bit of a bit of a
tight situation here I don't think
there's any way out of this one nemesis
locked up he's locked up I'm locked up
too okay here we go bleep fake Bob okay
made it alright he's probably very close
by me but I didn't find my last thing no
no maybe that's what happened when I got
spotted by the spotlight he's been
waiting for me ever since no which is a
bit of a problem but oh well what can
you do I don't know where can I go I
don't understand oh look maybe there's
something like round the back edges of
the toy factory oh no he's stuck right
there okay I see him I see you I see you
friend okay
oh hi whoa oh whoa hi um okay it's gotta
be something to do with that toy factory
right it's gotta be it's gotta be
something to do with the toy factory
it's gotta be that's the only other
place I haven't been and it seems so big
and important that you'd think that it
would be something that's important I
don't know why else would you be here
why else would you be so big and
important oh Jesus oh this is not a good
idea okay there I go well [ __ ]
dude I don't even know oh where am I now
huh I don't know oh well [ __ ] well I
think I goof that there may be a way
that I could like swing jump around I
don't know if I could hum price still
bone oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho
what the [ __ ] whoo whoo I was just
double-checking this place you don't
need to come in here Santa [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] off you don't need to do anything
that's not good
all right I know what I don't actually
know where to go Santa
so you killing me and that I don't even
know oh my god
[Music]
oh I don't know okay well there's that
then okay
I don't know what to do I'm I'm at a
complete loss up and running around in
circles I've checked back on every home
I thought I did I even jumped up on the
roofs hoping that there would be like
some some kind of subtle entrance up
here but it seems like that is a big ol
Noboru knee I can't make that jump no I
don't know man I don't know and I don't
know where okay Laurie whoa what what
what why what what is what is that
supposed to mean I don't even know what
that is I don't even understand what
you're trying to tell me are you just
doing that just book me why oh I don't
know does that mean Kris Kringle is are
coming because if he is that's that's no
good but at this point I don't know what
else to do besides let him try to kill
me oh there we go I guess sure
whoa whoa whoa
okay well I ran out of lives I have no
idea what I was supposed to do there but
I died to Santa and I think that's a
sign so anyway I'll end that there if
you guys want to see if there's any more
to that
yeah I'll provide a link in the
description below again it's I think
it's just a demo it's not the full
release of the game but these games are
always very fascinating to me because
they're forcibly made in an old VHS like
80s style like bloody horror it's a lot
of fun so thank you everybody someone
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below as
always see you in the next video
[Music]